so our second speaker tonight is Adam
vrat um at neural Alpha who I know very
well as CEO of neural ala having worked
with him for the last is it four years
probably feels like longer to
you I would say I taught Adam everything
he knows having worked in the graph
space for the last kind of 10 or 15
years but unfortunately I think it's
probably the other way around and
actually Adams kind of taught me quite a
lot about graphs over the last five
years of uh working together so big
round of Applause and warm welcome to
Adam Thanks James um okay so I'm uh my
name is Adam vrad I'm uh lead near new
Alpha uh first a bit about me I
graduated from Kings College London with
a master's degree in computer science
and artificial intelligence I've been at
new Ala for uh almost 5 years now and uh
I've work on a variety of uh projects
involving data integration knowledge
graphs uh spatial data and
AI uh a bit about neuro Alpha we are uh
sustainable fch uh consultancy and uh we
we we focus on on building the pooke
software solutions for banks and asset
managers uh when it comes to
sustainability side we we focus mostly
on the E side of ESG so the environment
and we also often use connected data
Technologies
um yeah apart from uh building BB
software Solutions we we also have
expertise in uh data V visualization uh
developing uh ESG data strategies and uh
data engineering uh ESG
research um so despite being a
consultancy we we do have our own uh
product which is a responsible Capital
platform and which uh I'm going to talk
about pieces of this platform today and
uh this uh platform is uh it's a
software is a service solution and data
product uh it's powered by a graph uh
that's why we are here and uh it's a
graph storing information about
organizations and all sorts of ESG
relevant data about this organizations
so uh like their physical assets
actually I I'll show you at the next
slide um and uh the most recent addition
to this platform is an llm based
chatbot uh that's the other part of the
reason why I why I'm speaking here um
which uh started as a separate thing and
because of that it currently in
production has nothing to do with the
graph part it's uh answering questions
about the company
disclosures uh so to to speed up
analysis of of companies so so the speed
up the manual research that that that
analy would do while uh you know going
through hundreds of uh
PDFs uh to to get some answers uh about
I don't know the company's policies on
on deforestation for
example some something like that
um so uh in the graph we we have all all
of these uh things and and like all of
these all of these aspects of of uh of
of the data that we we store in our ESG
graph that is powering this platform and
uh then there are disclosures are the
the odd one out because they are just
PDFs on S3 and the embeddings in Vector
store but uh until now so what I'm going
to talk about they had nothing I mean
they we still didn't ingest them in the
into the graph but the bot uh I think
the point what I'm trying to say is that
the bot was only seeing this not the
whole picture this was only focusing on
the disclosures and the the the
uh the goal of this exercise uh that I
worked through uh and I based this
presentation on is to to enable the bot
to query r they get the rest of our data
uh so so it's uh smarter and more
helpful
um so so the current setup is the
classic uh rug on on documents we have a
vector store where we have Chun the we
chunk the documents uh we embed them
store in the vector store and then uh
when user has a question we we try to
retrieve the most relevant chunks and
and use them to to answer the
question uh
and there are some it's a bit more
complicated than that sometimes we get
back to get more documents sometimes we
have to reduct the answer when we think
that uh that that maybe the it's not
based enough in these pieces of
documents like like may we make it
question itself because it tends to
increase the the quality but uh this is
essential is it's a very extrem light
process there is no no place for
like choosing different data sources
choosing uh choosing different options
it's just get documents answer a
question and so
uh so we wanted to introduce the rack on
graphs into the mix so so so it can uh
not only take from the documents but
also from the graph and when I looked at
it uh the the main two options uh it
seemed to me where like direct access
giving it direct access so um if we
allow it to read graph schema and and
give a couple of examples of Cipher
queries it could generate Cipher queries
I think I didn't mention it's a neo4j
graph but it's a neo4j graph and we
query it in Cypher um it could generate
these queries but uh but it doesn't seem
very stable to me uh so uh there a the
the other approach uh I mean I will get
back to it but the other approach is uh
using a semantic layer so that's where
it doesn't directly access the graph we
Define the set of tools and uh we which
which have some Cipher templates and uh
the the llm calls these tools with with
arguments and gets the answers so so we
we have a lot of control over how and uh
when it queries the the
graph um it seems just much more uh
reasonable because
uh like like we don't know what queries
it could generate like would it be would
it be too not not optimize enough would
it run run for for a long time would it
actually understand the the the the
schema or would it only generate queries
that don't fail but maybe don't make
that much sense in real life so so uh it
was Nob brainer for me to to go for this
uh semantic layer approach and how we
implemented is is we we looked at our we
redefined our bot because previously it
wasn't much of an agent uh it was uh it
was a chain if you if you think think in
terms of like how L chain call call
thing call things uh it's a like a
streamlined process and wanted to
introduce agency here so so the the the
B is an a that has a set of tools at its
disposition and
uh and depending on the question it can
choose how I want to query the
disclosures or I want to see what graph
says about this or that I want to choose
choose this of that tool and then
optionally uh go back and use another
tool and another or maybe use the same
tool twice as long unless it's um until
it has the the enough information to to
generate a uh response
so uh I'm going to talk through some of
these tools we defined so first of all I
I needed to define a tool uh to to
search disclosure documents because we
wanted to replicate in in this new
approach replicate uh what we already
have uh so so this tool is effectively
our whole previous uh pipeline or the
our whole previous approach packed into
one tool that is only subset of of the
whole thing does now uh it's again a
query it's optimized embedded compared
with uh other vectors uh we retrieve
relevant documents answer but but this
time uh llm is triggering this and the
llm is looking at the results and and
possibly answering possibly using other
tools in in together with this one and
uh as I talk through these tools I've
decided I'm going to show an example
that will be like it will be a continued
scenario through all of presenting all
of these tools and every time I'll show
like before and
after and in the first uh first for in
the first example it doesn't make that
much sense because uh before case is no
tools where and the bot is instructed
not to use any information from that
don't come from the tools so uh I'm not
I don't expect you to read all of that
I'm going to to it's just a proof that
it works and I actually got these
answers in the terminal and you can try
to read it but I'm going to tell you in
a second um so before no tools no no
answers because it's been instructed not
to answer there's no information no zero
tools means zero information uh all is
zero information it's been instructed to
use uh so after so so the in this
example we are asking uh what are glenor
policies on human rights um and it's
with this tool it was able to read
disclosures uh and and and describe the
policies based on a human rights policy
PDF or some something like that and uh
that's not that interesting let's go to
the graph part uh so second tool is the
first tool where where graphs come in
it's the most basic one by far uh it's
just Cy crate retrieving attributes of
the organization not but you know I had
to talk about because it's still rck on
graphs uh even though this could would
be a I suppose a relational database
record or or like a document store
record nothing special about it but uh
but but with this information now be
before if I ask about their website they
would say oh I don't know I'm just an AI
I don't know the URL you have to Google
it um after introducing this tool it you
to retrieve the note from the graph have
a look at these attributes and figure
out that the website is glore.com
um tool number three uh it's probably
the the most complicated one uh is uh is
getting news articles by topic so I
don't know if I mentioned ear in the
graph we have this news articles that
are connected to our ESG taxonomy as
well as uh as the organizations so we
can uh query for um news related to
different ESG Concepts uh
um and connected to to the organization
we are interested in so here I uh I
generated embeddings uh I use llm to
generate embeddings of all our SC
Concepts in the in
our uh ESG uh
taxonomy
uh and uh and for given topic this what
is like just this um drawing of this
tool this top this tool receives a topic
embeds it compares with this cost
Concepts chooses the most similar one
and uh and looks for news that are
connected to it via sometimes via like
multiple like via longer path of related
Concepts and to this organization um
that's um I guess maybe now I I I should
say in this in all of all of these tools
uh don't allow the bot to choose the
organization it's we are asking about
because that's how our platform works
that the the chat is located at the
company profile so we it's predefined
what organization you are asking about
so um you can even not mention the
organization in the question and it will
it will know so uh just if in case
anyone wondered why I I don't mention
this part of how do we identify which
organization because we we just have
organization ID at this point um yeah so
so then we retrieve this these news
articles with title text dates and uh
I'm not sure there might be more
attributes I I don't remember thatmore
these are the ones I chose to to use in
this graphic and uh then be I I like
this example and again I'm going to tell
you what what it says uh before when I
ask about I said these human rights
policies look sound good but are they
actually following them so it's a
continuation of the conversation where I
ask about human rights policies and it
defined them based on the
disclosures um and it's so you looked at
disclosures again and and said oh based
on the disclosures see they basically
they look fine they have a lot of
Promise make a lot of like promises and
have a lot of policies and and all of
that and and it sounds good uh but um as
it highlights at the end uh it would be
good to look at third party Audits and
news articles and blah but it's not able
to do that so uh adding this third tool
um made it answer a completely different
answer uh it looked at news articles
because we already know what disclosures
say and uh it highlighted how u in
Colombia communities near seron coal
mine owned by glenor have reported
environmental crisises health issues and
displacement of indigenous and afro
Colombian Colombian communities and I'm
not going to read the rest but there is
uh mentions of conflict minerals child
labor forc labor and all sort of uh
things that that don't sound that good
um in terms of uh human rights abuses
and um and and it it sums up that
clearly there are some issues with the
implementation of these policies that
sound so good
um so the the fourth tool is uh is
looking at the physical assets the
organization owns So for given list of
the names of the assets
we retrieve the assets what the
Commodities they produce um the assets
owned by this organization we are
looking at again or its
subsidiaries uh and I also uh it will
make sense why but I also included
Neighbors in in this one it was easy
enough to do we have the coordinates of
these assets so we just uh retrieved
neighboring like neighboring mine to
this mine we are looking at or in this
example
and
uh and in this case I asked uh so the it
meant that news story you just quoted
mentioned the Colombian mine uh are
there other assets near it that could
also contribute to these issues uh
environmental and and social issues that
were mentioned and it is it just said
something like how something about
ownership of the mind then it mentions
some there is some operation that is
near it and uh it did it wasn't very
very convincing so I asked how do you
know this operation is near uh that mine
and it said that according to
disclosures it's in Colombia so like
okay it's in Colombia so it's near Great
uh that's not what I was asking about
and when I introduced this this final
Tool uh when I asked the same question
it was able to to call this this Tool uh
retrieve a list of uh assets matching
the this Kon uh s so sah um call my name
and uh and retrieve the free facilities
that are uh within a couple of
kilometers away and it knew like who
owns them uh what do they produce and uh
I mean it's just much more useful answer
and if we wanted we could ask more about
give me the coordinates of the papayal
call mine and then we could maybe look
at it on Google Maps or or something
like that um okay okay
uh yeah questions and maybe I just just
final note uh obviously that that
there's a lot more data points that we
would like to make the B be able to to
to access this way there's a lot of a
lot more Noe types there's a lot more in
our ESG taxonomy we can we can utilize
this way so I'm excited to to do that
next but this is just and also I have to
say this is in development it's not in
production the current if you go to
responsib
capital. uh what you will find is a bot
that only answers questions about
disclosures for now but uh this is what
I've been working on recently and uh
yeah do we have any questions and
answers uh sorry questions do we have
any
questions uh
sorry soor to to do
what uh to do to do evaluation yeah yeah
it's it's it is hard we we we have some
uh some code to uh have some code to do
that but to be honest we are
uh a bit under resource and I wish we
could do more of
this
uh yeah
um yeah what can I say it's hard we we
also have our like ESG analy that can
look at analyze a lot of questions and
example answers and uh not example
generated answers and compare with what
they would say we also run experiments
with some of our potential clients for
this to not not with the graph part
because that's very new but with the
with the documents and and
U I don't remember exactly maybe James
remembers but the the Phoenix
uh no you know so I'm putting a human
spot sorry what was the
question oh we run an experiment where
the potential client compar the answers
uh based on disclosures of their ass of
our assessment with the assessment their
humans uh their humans did uh the their
employees did yeah yeah so I guess I
mean I guess one of the headline metrics
that we've achieved with um with with um
so the kind of llm and graph combination
is um at the moment it takes kind of
human analysts around 3 to 5 days to do
an ESG assessment of a company so
combing through anything from 10 ESG
disclosures to potentially hundreds for
a listed company um and we're we're able
to get that down to a few hours um and
we've done Pilots with various companies
where the accuracy has been within kind
of 5% tolerance of what a human would
generate um so so you know conduct say
an ESG assessment over a portfolio of
dozens of companies that would have been
you know weeks if not months worth of
work previously in kind of hours or you
know a couple of days so um
yeah someone yeah sorry just probably
because it's a follow on of what you
just said so the if I understand the the
way in which this is used is as much as
anything you pose it a question and then
you let the system go and do its thing
it might take a couple of hours to come
with answer or it's an interactive
process where the hum's in the loop so
for for one organization it's
interactive it's a chatbot but we have
this batch uh what's it called uh guess
what we call it internally it's not what
it's called on the platform but
essentially it's a way of asking batch
of questions over batch of organizations
so you can define a list like we call it
question set of 30 questions um have
your portfolio of 100 organizations and
you you run it and it takes I know 25
minutes or half an hour and you come
back and you have a table uh like a
special thing there that we also have uh
that we don't have in the chat is uh we
allow you to enforce types so the uh to
to to ask for bullan answer number
answer textual answer uh enum answer so
then uh the resulting table the the
columns in the resulting table have
specific types so you can uh create
charts or analyze them in other ways
then you don't just have a lot of
sentences in every cell and and you have
to read through all of that to to get
anything out of it um I I think you were
sorry to top free queries I'm sure maybe
this
misunderstanding
uh uh I mean in these cases where we do
it here now it's always uh it always
happens after the the uh the agent
already decides what to do so uh the
question is um in this specific example
we're looking at the question is
uh
uh what are the glenor policies on human
rights and uh the our chatbot agent or
llm or however we call it looks at this
question and no we we give it
information you have these four tools
and it decides okay I want to call this
tool with argument human rights so then
this tool what it this tool knows is
just I got an input topic human rights I
want to find everything on human and
then it Compares embedded human rights
with uh embedded uh scuss Concepts
uh uh currently it only presents
information so it's just uh like a
research copilot kind of thing no it
doesn't uh like it doesn't design a
portfolio for you Bas oh I want a
sustainable portfolio it's something it
could be interesting to explore in the
future
um um yeah so so these are these tools
are essentially python functions and
it's it's we are using for for this at
least for this proof of concept maybe
that's not what we will use in the final
version but we are using L chain uh
agent and uh lank chain tools and uh why
I call this semantic layer because I've
seen it called this way in a couple of
places uh I know it sounds uh fancy and
maybe I I'm saying something I'm not I I
didn't intend to say but I I did see it
called this way and couple of plates so
that's
yeah no
no no no I define i define these tools
which are python functions and I allowed
the and I defined uh what they do and
provided that information to the to the
model
prompt so it's a bit will be a bit
random okay it it's actually a linked
question because semantic layer is what
I was thinking as well so is semantic
layer essentially a rules based engine
so once the four tools have been given
uh some rules have been given as well or
is the semantic layer the decisions or
the choices are made by the agent
without any rules being given so I was
thinking about probabilistic search
versus determin deterministic search in
terms of rule based versus herotic or
whatever is the llm it's not rules based
L it's not rules B it's not it's the llm
chooses what to use based on the
question so it is still probalistic
yeah yeah probalistic
okay okay thank
you oh
it's definitely something we thought
about it's not implemented any way
before because green washing was in a
problem when we only had disclosures
because what we are saying we are not
saying we give you the truth we are
saying we give you the truth about what
the company says right so it's we just
help help you figure out what the com
what is this this company's position on
this or that so uh now that we introduce
third party sources it could be
interesting to look into it because news
articles could be good but could be good
journalism or green washing and uh maybe
one way to do it is is generate generate
some sort of score based on how much of
given
a new source align with what the company
says if is 100% aligned maybe they're
always maybe they're green washing maybe
that's one example of a of but no it's
just the first thing I I would maybe try
but but but we I haven't we haven't done
the work so I can't say what works just
just
guess uh
was yeah sure I'm just I'm interested in
the uh Discovery and development process
around the tools so you mentioned that
you have four tools I'm interested to
know if you tried adding other tools how
you've gotten tested if a new tool was
actually helping or actually making
things worse um I'm interested around
that kind of process that you've gone
through um to be honest it's early days
so it's been just the tools that I I've
had time to to add
and and there's I have a lot of more my
more ideas and uh I guess you see all
these examples that I tried with and
without tool and then but but you could
say it's a it was a cherry pecked
scenario where it's perfectly with every
tool you get a better answer kind of
deal but um maybe it's not always the
case I think it's too early too sa for
us sorry I I can't uh be an expert on
this and and provide you with uh the
answer just just just show and
tell
really cool I think we've um run out of
time in terms of questions